casimir peux tu me passes et une brosse
mon écharpe et août salle une à brassens
une
voie là
non kazimierz elle brosse est beaucoup
trop grosse enfin elle va arracher tout
le tissu ballon tu n'as rien donc à
temps je regarde un
voile à celle ci ça ira ça mais casimir
comment oses tu me donner cette brosse
c'est une grosse à chaussures qui
prennent de cirage en plus je n'avais
pas vu un bond à temps je regarde si
j'ai à autre chose
voilà
voilà tiens comme celle ci mais ils
n'ont qu'un semir ça c'est une brosse à
ongles elle est beaucoup trop dur n'est
pas possible allez tu vraiment difficile
un bon je regarde si j'en ai une plus
souple ouais bah voilà ça ira ça voilà
une crainte souple
mais je rêve
la brosse à dos non mais tu te moques de
moi
ma brosse hâte au match tout est
vraiment difficile 1 j'essaye dois te
faire plaisir et tu n'es jamais content
tiens voilà des brosses un déroutement
richard
casimir
si je suis agacé comme ça c'est surtout
parce que j'habite chez l'habitant le
plus stupide de lille voilà quoi moi
stupide mois casimir le sol descendant
de la grande lignée des casimir eux sans
l'arrière arrière arrière petit fils de
casimir aux ramiers cela reste à prouver
qu'est ce que tu as à dire moi je disais
c'est la pure vérité
menteur j'ai parfaitement entendu
qu'andy cela reste à prouver eh bien je
vais te le prouver tiens regarde
ceci est le portrait de mon ancêtre
casimir aux premiers jeux les retrouver
au grenier
n'est pas très ressemblants bon j'ai
d'autres grands vins
regarde tient cette vieille carte oui
c'est une carte de l'île aux enfants de
plusieurs siècles avec ici le château de
mes ancêtres il a été démoli il n'en
reste plus rien ce n'est donc pas une
preuve bon ça ne fait rien j'ai d'autres
preuves
celle ci tu ne pourras pas la contester
c'est mon arbre généalogique
général au coin
généalogique 1 qu'est ce que c'est eh
bien ceux ci expliquent tout hein mon
ascendance 1 1 ici c'est moi puis il ya
mon père mon grand père mon argent
il n'y a pas de photos bon évidemment à
cette époque là les photos n'existait
pas c'est bien dommage
puisque je n'arrive pas à convaincre
je vais aller voir monsieur du snav lui
saura trouver les arguments pour te
convaincre
un soi-disant descendant des rois
casimir puisqu'il peut même par me
trouver une brosse qui me convient
monsieur du sna bas je suis vraiment
content de vous trouver là tout le
plaisir est pour moi vont casimir de
quoi s'agit-il vous êtes je crois un
spécialiste de l'histoire des anciennes
familles à mieux vu dano tu devrais
casimir j'ai étudié évident non plus
spécialement ma grande famille mais
comme ma grande famille a rencontré
toutes les grandes familles je connais
donc l'histoire de toutes les grandes
familles
que c'est bon non ménopausées s'appelle
la simplicité dans la grandeur mais en
quoi puis je être utile comme vous savez
oui je descends du grand roi casimiro le
premier c'est sûr léonard lui ne veux
pas me croire quoi bon sens et un sens
ce n'est pas de croire
quoique sur le plan des preuves c'est
pas sympa à l'épreuve en voilà une bonne
c'est mon arbre généalogique
c'est bien aussi non mais je ne doute
pas que tu descente de casimir us
premier seulement
pas de portrait pas de photos le cas est
difficile quasiment voici monsieur du
snam je ne comprends pas personne n'a
jamais mis en doute mon origine enfin
que se passe-t-il pour un coût de denner
veut pas casimir ne t'énerve pas je vais
faire des recherches ce n'est pas la
peine monsieur dix neuf je m'en charger
et moi même
c'est quand même incroyable d'être être
contestée par us normes qui prétend
avoir rencontré des gens de qualité
simplement parce qu'il les a croisés
dans la rue
ce casimir en tout cas un talon c'est
celui de mettre de mauvaise humeur
monsieur disnat oui vous n'avez pas vu
casimir non ma chère amy je n'ai pas vu
quasiment
il va certainement pas tarder
ah
bonjour merci du snav bonjour mon beau
françois bon jour ainsi du snob vous
n'avez pas vu non je n'ai pas vu khademi
vous fâchez pas je me fâche pas manger
pas chargée de surveiller les allées et
venues de casimir taton excusez moi
monsieur distance je vais pas vous
déranger plus dans le temps
bonjour julie
ce n'est pas de très bonne humeur
tu n'as pas vu casimir non pas encore
mais à mon avis la mauvaise humeur de
lucius la pensée que casimir est déjà
passé dans le jardin oui certainement et
moi je suis bien ennuyés parce que je
voulais faire un jeu justement avec la
collaboration de casimir et maintenant
bon bah savais rien je vais me
débrouiller tout seuls les enfants les
enfants venez venez nous allons faire un
jeu je vais vous montrer des dessins et
vous allez me
ça alors mes dessins ont disparu les
enfants je suis navré vraiment mais
aujourd'hui n'y aura pas de jeu mais mes
dessins ont disparu et excusez moi une
autre fois vendin allait jouer
attendez ne partez pas c'est moi qui
allais destin commence à kazimiyah mais
tu peux m'expliquer pourquoi tu as pris
mon carton à 17 plus tard françois plus
tard commençons le jeu d'après mes
calculs au bon j'avoue montré des
portraits de personnages célèbres et
vous allez me dire leur nom d'accord les
enfants alors voilà le premier
personnage célèbre
alors mes casini comment se fait-il que
que son visage soit collé ou non je ne
sais pas maintenant n'occupe pas un
continue bien qu'y at-il en dessous
c'est la joconde qui est la joconde
oui
c'était sympa
et qui se trouve dans quel musée haut
musée du louvre à paris
deuxième personnage célèbre
casimir je retire ton visage alors c'est
king kong king kong les enfants
un voleur de nos casinos toi tu n'es pas
un véritable monstre bien c'est king
kong le suivant à ils sont trois quarts
puisque casimir évidemment s'est mis en
plein milieu et rami losc comment
s'appelle-t-il
d'artagnan à d'artagnan certaines y ans
et un quatrième qui n'est pas sur le
dessin et d'où viennent les trois
mousquetaires
d'un roman très célèbre de
d'alexandre dumas tiens
personnages suivants
oui qu'est ce qu'a fait casimir fille de
15 ans et où vivaient tard zone
il avait une gueule non je crois que ça
fait comment j'ai dit j'ai dit
si tu as tort évidemment casimir au
milieu ensuite
la liberté
à l'entrée du port et vous savez qui a
donné la statue de la liberté à la ville
de new york ce sont les français
nous en avons encore un autre
casimir au milieu quel est ce personnage
voit-il surtout vécu
dans un château immense il a fait
construire et qui se trouve à versailles
sont les jardins ont été dessinés par un
jardinier très sélect qui s'appelle le
nôtre
ensuite celui-ci
leur fierté guinéen et où se trouvent
en égypte dans le désert pas loin du
caire désigne maintenant j'aimerais
régler un petit conte comment se fait-il
que ton visage se trouve à chaque fois
au milieu du dessin je vais tout
expliquer un j'ai arrangé un petit peu
ces dessins pour que l'on ne puisse plus
dire quand je n'ai pas d'ancêtres
célèbre et que les quotas ziri casimir
aux premiers eh bien mon ancêtre
[Musique]